make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are picking back
up again with swords of x in this
instance we kind of join with cable all
right we pick up with cable cyclops and
jean grey while they are on board what's
called the peak which
is the main operating base of sword so a
little bit of history here when it comes
to marvel comics because i feel like
it's important to explain the nature of
sword
because we're going to see them in the
mcu so sword stands for the sentient
world observation and response
department and this was not
a thing that existed until astonishing
x-men
by joss whedon the whole idea behind
this is that in marvel comics you have
shield and shield has been around for a
long long time
the name for shield the acronym has
changed over the years but the idea is
that shield was designed to monitor
threats to
earth right to basically monitor earth
itself but where shield monitored earth
sword monitored space and sword would
look out for like galactus coming to
earth
or like the the scrolls who were looking
to launch an attack on earth or the the
cree or something like that and they
would warn the superheroes accordingly
or if they had the power to handle it on
their own they would take care of it
themselves now the leader of sword was a
woman named abigail brand and abigail
brand had the ability to understand and
speak
any language in existence right now she
was the leader for a long time from 2004
when astonishing x-men first came out
running all the way
up until all new all different marvel
and when that kicked off that's when you
had
carol danvers who took over as director
of sword and then sword was renamed to
the alpha flight program
and so it's kind of been that way ever
since now what involvement carol danvers
has in sword or the new alpha flight i'm
not really even sure in this day and age
i haven't read our comics for two years
so i have no clue what's going on in the
carol danvers line of comics but the
whole idea here is that that sword has
more or less kind of been shut down now
this ties into cable and jean grey and
and cyclops by way the fact that the
cable sword is one of the 10 swords they
need
for the swords of x event right for the
10 swords challenge but he had plugged
it in
to the end of the peak in order to power
it back up to kind of find out what's
been going on here and as they're going
through and as they're investigating of
course magic chimes in as we saw in a
previous video where she told cable hey
like we need you back here right like
you need to come
back here you know we need your sword
the light of galador all that kind of
stuff now a funny thing about the sword
of of cable the light of gallaudet is
this is one of those instances
when what's going on in the x-men
universe because it's being led by
jonathan hickman ties back into the work
that jonathan hickman already did and
it's one of the reasons why i'm glad
that we did avengers and new avengers
because if you recall in that story when
we were kind of leading up to the events
of
infinity we had the builders and the
builders had literally appeared in the
main marvel universe and were making
their way towards earth with the
intention of destroying it but the idea
is that along their way to earth when
they entered into the main marvel
universe
they ended up annihilating all life on
the planet galador and gallador is a
world that belongs to a group called the
space nights and space nights are quite
literally just like a peacekeeping force
of individuals who have undergone a
procedure that converts them from
strictly you know whatever their organic
nature was to becoming a kind of machine
with a human mind their essences and
their consciousness are backed up into
those
robots and then they kind of go forward
accordingly but the idea was that
uh at some point with the reformation of
the multiverse it was kind of a
reference to the collect to the the
events leading up to the collapse of the
multiverse to the builders and when
cable got his hands on the sword on the
light of galador it led to a great huge
battle with a whole bunch of galadorian
space nights the fact that cable still
has the sword kind of tells you how that
battle ended up going down because i'm
trying to find
i like the idea of what we did with
avengers new avengers where we had like
the comics that we were normally
covering and then as like a background
series we just had like an enormous
series taking place
and i'm kind of debating on what i want
to do next if i want to do something
like uncanny
uncanny avengers if i want to do
something like like rick remembers
avengers run or
x-men run or was it uncanny x-force that
he did if we do something like we
continue green lantern i'm kind of
figuring out what it is that i want to
do
right so make sure you guys leave some
comments down below and give me some
ideas
but uh that's kind of how we are with
regards to cable having this sword
but the cool thing about this is is
again magic's like hey you got to come
back here right like you got to come
back to earth uh and you have to
basically you know give us your sword or
at least stand here with your swords you
can be part of the circle kibble's
response is i'll be back here in a
little bit
we gotta check out what's going on here
now the funny thing about this is that
with the station being powered down this
never really happens
we never really see instances where
sword is not operating inside of its
base of operations
the fact that they're seemingly nobody
there indicates that
something really bad happened here
that's really kind of what's going on
and so what you end up getting is this
kind of realization that there's this
bulkhead that's sealed shut and that it
had been done in a hurry
right like somebody had wielded it super
fast and so the only time you do that is
when you're trying to keep something out
and so of course
the x-men open it like why not and so
once they open the door they end up
calling for jean grey right now jean
grey and of course cyclops and and uh
cable had kind of split
and so what she ends up doing is it's
going you know kind of discovering this
making this little discovery of herself
she finds one person inside this whole
space station right just kind of sitting
on the bridge and when she gets in there
this person kind of says like like ask
her a few questions like you turn the
power back on like
you basically powered the station back
on why would you do that the indication
here
is that initially there was just kind of
like a sound right
they heard these different sounds
basically the sounds of people dying
right it was kind of like a rhythm where
you would hear people dying then you
would hear silence and you would hear
people dying and then you would hear
silence and it was just it was it was
repeating and then they ended up
realizing it was a sound they were
hearing in their head that it was just
kind of going
through their heads over and over and
over again and that half the station was
wiped out before they could even regroup
or understand what was really going on
and so what you end up finding out is
that those individuals who weren't wiped
out were seemingly taken over by some
kind of a force
right and this guy has been taken over
by part of that force and so what you
end up having is jean grey who tries to
read his mind and figure out what's
going on and she can't
she's basically met by this kind of of
blocking right in the sense that
whatever this is that took over the sky
the first thing they did was fortify
their minds against telepathy and so
what this shows is a handful of
different things
one it shows intelligence rational
thinking and two it shows the ability to
overcome powers right you cannot
overcome a power that you're not
familiar with and so because of that it
means they're familiar with telepathy
right if you didn't know what telepathy
was how would you know how to overcome
that power
because of that jean grey kind of
experiences this sort of psychic
backlash to a degree and this guy
basically says like you know we pledged
our lives to defend this world and
nobody ever came for us and so what it
indicates is they sent out an
sos this guy yanks the airlock and ends
up sucking himself out so i guess he's
on an airlock and not the bridge right
but like he ends up sucking himself out
into space and the guy dies and so when
jean grey hits him up and says are you
guys still in the science slide right
hit some cyclops says are you guys still
on the science lab the response is
yes and she's like do not open anything
like do not open any doors don't do
anything like i'm getting over there as
fast as i can whatever it is on this
thing killed everybody on the space
station and the response of cyclops is
we know and that's when cable asks this
interesting question did saturnine know
we'd find this and that it would
probably try to kill us right is she
hoping that it would try to kill us now
the thing about this is that jean grey
got a little bit of a kind of
glimpse here in terms of what was going
on and what she says is that this this
space station was infiltrated by
something called the viscora right kind
of like a faceless death right is what
it's kind of referred to here it's a
little bit ambiguous but you do see a
couple of them come out and then you end
up seeing you know the x-men basically
attack them and essentially destroy them
right which means
they can be they can be killed but they
kind of say these things like cleanse
this reality is already fetid right like
we're going to cleanse this whole
reality
and seemingly move on to the next one
and so it kind of gives premise to the
idea that they're multi-dimensional or
multi-universal forces right so like
they go from one universal space to the
next doing whatever it is that they do
but the important thing is that jean
grey actually kind of
kind of uses astral projection and her
essence more or less leaves her body
and travels through this portal and into
the other side and that's when you end
up seeing that there is essentially just
this massive
portal more or less or the source from
which they're all emanating from and
pouring in right and that and the
response of gene is kill everybody that
you see right like kill every single one
you can possibly find and so it's one of
these things where like the whole
station kind of lurches right cable sent
on this mission
set on this task to go and grab his
sword and to pull it up pull it out of
the core
and basically depower the ship which
would shut the portal back down again
and of course he successfully does right
everything's kind of shut back down and
then it's like okay like what do we do
here
what this does is it kind of picks up
with one of those little interim pages
they give us where they kind of fill in
the gaps by kind of giving us some some
kind of let over the crazy thing about
this is that in the span of 10 minutes
right in the span of 10 minutes
an anomaly is detected in science lab 14
that personal transponders of the entire
science division are terminated so they
don't know
their stasis they don't know if they're
living if they're dead or any of that
stuff
and so in response to that hostile
boarding boarding protocols are
initiated fire teams are just are
deployed on search and rescue missions
right so they're searching lab 14 and
that associated part of the ship to find
out what's going on
and so from there fire team deployment
shifted to recovery and then they
manually attempt to depressurize lab 14
which is basically prevented by failsafe
they try to
they they try to like cut it off from
the ship right they try to open an
airlock and suck out whatever's in there
right so whatever's in there is
literally wreaking havoc from there
you're seven minutes in
to like this initial indication that
something's wrong and it's a mass
casualty event 32
of the peak crew has been terminated in
a non-decompression event that began in
lab 14. basically saying some kind of an
anomaly was detected
this portal something came through the
portal and basically started attacking
them
from there you go into safety protocols
or overwritten by station command right
so the indication
is that whatever this is that's been
taking over people managed to make its
way to the command deck and then in turn
is basically making it possible for this
to spread and then you go into general
quarters right which is
anybody who's kind of out there and not
working at the moment and 55
of them are all killed tactical approval
for fire team deployment through the
incursion gate so basically we're going
to go to the other side and find out
what's going on uh and then it's power
draining from core
to lab 14 which is there's something in
there that's basically powering itself
up then you go into power unstable comms
array life support and orbital systems
are all compromised this ship is
effectively shutting down right because
the core is being depowered then you get
into 78
of peak crew has been terminated and
then siege of lab 14 was totally
unsuccessful command mission to
dismantle power station successful power
level
is reduced completely and totally right
so basically they shut the whole thing
down
in the span of 10 minutes they detected
some kind of an anomaly this anomaly
took out everybody in the science lab it
spread like wildfire
it basically took over other individuals
which ensured its progression throughout
the ship
it started wiping out as many people as
it possibly could to the point that 78
of the entire crew was killed and then
they ended up having to shut the ship
down in order to get this thing under
control
now in terms of what this was and and
how all this worked the only thing we
really know here is it's some kind of a
virus right some kind of like a living
virus and that's it we don't get
anything else besides that instead you
have cable who comes through the comes
to the portal from you know into kakoa
with the light of galador and then says
okay
and takes a stance on the on the the
actual on his little icon right on his
little thing here and that's it right
now from there you have a cyclops and
you have gene who make their way out and
you have uh
magic who's basically engaging in an
essentially a telepathic conversation
with them now the funny thing about this
is we're not given a
clear on understanding of what they're
talking about the indication here
is that they plan on running some kind
of basic backdoor
you know event like some kind of
backdoor or uh backdoor campaign or
something like that right like you kind
of have this conversation that comes out
you got jean grey and cyclops
like is it just me or does it look like
it's going to rain the response of magic
is it feels like it's going to come down
like daggers you're like do you have a
plan the response to cyclops is you know
i've been noodling on some things
two main problems communication and
transportation and it's like well we
have some suggestions for rides but
communication is not my strong suit and
and then gene turns says other world is
locked down uh telepathically but i
think we could punch our way through
if we had enough of us working on it can
it be done the response of gene is it
has to be done
something's going on here like we're not
fully aware of what it is but
something's taking place here right and
the response of magic is okay if you
guys need me to i can keep an eye on
cable make sure that he does what he's
supposed to do that he's none the wiser
of what's happening the
the indication here and we're not we're
not given it's not really on the nose
but the indication here is that whatever
was on that ship
seemingly took over cyclops and gene i'm
not gonna swear to that and i could be
entirely wrong
it could have to do with the plan that
we've seen unfolding right kakoa kind of
implementing its own plan with regards
to how to steal the swords from the from
the enemy side and it's a multi-faceted
plan right it's not just the marauders
who were doing it it's cyclops and gene
launching their own plan
probably other direction of charles
xavier we're not entirely sure that's
one of the things about this is with us
being 22 parts we're only in like part
10
right now right so we're not even
halfway through uh really i think it's
more like part eight right now right so
we're not even close to halfway through
and we're still in that section
where we get more questions than we do
answers but regardless it's cool like i
dig this
i think this is gonna be one of those
stories like so many jonathan hickman
stories
where it kind of reads better in trade
right like when you have the whole thing
collected and you can go
you can read it all in one go but of
course we'll find out by the time we get
to the end but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comics explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
one
[Music]